just to repeat that this is the biggest
power station in in Europe nuclear power
station in Europe and if something
happens so there will be
huge consequences not only for Ukraine
probably all Ukraine will be
contaminated
but for Europe as well on the evening of
August of 6 August uh
2022 the Russian Armed Forces fired
rockets at underhada City
also hitting the Parisian NPP site
directly next to the dry storage of
spent nuclear fuel very dangerous
apparently they aimed specifically at
the casts was spent
fuel which are stored in the open near
the site of selling currently there are
174 casks there each containing 24
Assemblies of spent nuclear fuel
can you imagine a potential disaster
as a result three radiation monitoring
sensors around the storage site were
damaged due to shelling
therefore timely detection and response
in case of deterioration of the
radiation situation or leakage of
radiation from container suspend nuclear
fuel is currently impossible president
zielinski reiterated that
nuclear Russian nuclear Terror requires
a stronger response from the
International Community sanctions on the
Russian nuclear industry and nuclear
fuel this is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign distance
[Music]